and yesterday and Jeremy Corbyn angry so
when that starts heating him and I know
Jarrell patterns I said gets nature that
we're gonna hit them in their
constituencies because your viewers
might may know that there's a hundred
and twenty constituencies that are
marginal that have to be one to form a
government than may only scraped over
likely twelve majority says she had to
go into coalition with wonderful DUP
that's great
we have no big shake-up
so Tommy actually has triggered
something and I think number ten will
start acknowledging labeling that the
supporters of made jars and Murray Rahim
Qasim and all the people that stood on
that stage fighting for having the guts
to do
conservatives little though they believe
in when we stood on stage in the appeal
I was a justice for the greatest
relevant from Canada lost their money by
issuing decent representation that's a
sad fact but Ezra Levant and others
raised this note for Tommy's team and I
think they're quite powerful let's see
what happens
to give a judgement until the end of the
month we've only got another week to go
in July
that's another week that Tommy is
incarcerated pace man names children are
not seeing mystic